Острів Галіндез, сім кілометрів від західного узбережжя Антарктиди, станція "Академік Вернадський".
Через два тижні після початку повномасштабного вторгнення
сюди вирушила 27-ма українська антарктична експедиція.
13 полярників мали пробути на станції рік, поки вдома триває війна.
Не тільки до тебе не приїдуть, а ти не зможеш поїхати, якщо щось станеться з тим, кого ти любиш.
Залишав батьків, бабусь, брата...
Не було відомо, чи ти зможеш повернутися додому, чи ти зможеш взагалі кудись повернутися.
Більш ніж рік потому багато чого змінилося.
Керівник експедиції Юрій Отруба разом із командою збираються додому.
Попереду - місяць дороги в Україну.
Останній день, скажімо так, сьогодні ми пообідаємо на Вернадського, а вже вечеряти будемо на судні.
Від'їжджаєш - і трішки сумно, але завжди сумуєш, коли вже приїхав додому і пробув певний час вдома,
то вже сумуєш за станцією.
А зараз якби такий певний ажіотаж, що від'їжджаєш, їдеш додому побачити своїх рідних, близьких.
Ось що побачили полярники, коли повернулися до Києва.
Ось це було в нас так все потріскано…
Це місце роботи Юрія - Національний антарктичний науковий центр.
Після обстрілу Києва 10 жовтня торік російська ракета впала поруч із будівлею.
Нині вікна замінили, але всередині ще триває ремонт.
Документи, наукові архіви, сувеніри вціліли, але поки тісняться в коридорі.
Від антарктичних спогадів - на душі тепліше.
Юрій і його колега по експедиції - метеорологиня Анжеліка Ганчук - згадують, як промайнув рік на станції.
Бачите, за рахунок того, що колір ніби всередину йде, ніби, як на перлах - це тоді перламутрова хмара.
Хмари, лід і сніг. Як справжній метеоролог Анжеліка в захваті від антарктичних стихій.
Ця зимівля стала для дівчини втіленням давньої мрії.
Для цього довелося пройти суворий відбір - 17 людей на місце.
Адже Антарктида - це не лише розвага.
Продукти на станцію доставляють лише в літню пору.
Це означає, що запаси свіжих фруктів і овочів виснажуються, тож раціон обмежений.
Коли ми їмо на станції багато білкової їжі,  вона не так добре перетравлюється, як коли ти це робиш із зеленю.
На собі це відчувається, як ти втрачаєш енергію поступово,
ти весь час сонливий, почуваєшся хворобливо через це.
До того ж, антарктична природа - це завжди випробування.
У метеорологів найскладніший виклик - це погода.
Тому що ми маємо працювати за будь-якої погоди.
У цьому і полягає наша робота.
Для того, щоб українцям зрозуміти, який там вітер...
Наприклад, у нас нещодавно, часто влітку бувають шквальні вітри, які ламають дерева.
Наприклад, для Києва це всього 15-20 метрів на секунду, так?
Штормовий вітер вже. І вже все, летить шкереберть.
А там, наприклад, це буде до 30 метрів на секунду, от у такий день.
У нас є традиція, що ми відкопуємо доріжку на джеті - наш причал,
тому що там краще причалювати човном, залишати його на певний час.
І в тому районі в цьому році в нас була висота снігу десь 4,20-4,60.
А взагалі по снігомірній рейці 3,5 метра випало.
Тобто ми побили певні рекорди в нашу зимівлю.
27-ма експедиція в Антарктиду була особливою,
бо вирушила на шостий континент, коли російські війська наступали на Київ.
Залишити станцію на рік без господаря - означало би збитки і для споруд станції, і для світової науки.
У нас би відбувся перерив наукових даних.
Все-таки станція в нас надзвичайно стара, і в нас є певні низки даних, які накопичуються і досліджуються з 60-х, 50-х років.
Це метеорологічні дані, це спостереження в даному регіоні, це геофізичне спостереження,
це так само на станції магнітна обсерваторія, яка слідкує за магнітним полем Землі,
і її дані там з 56-го року надходять у світову мережу.
До 1996 року станція належала Великобританії, потім комплекс споруд передали Україні.
Британці й досі часто навідуються в гості, кажуть полярники.
А от з росіянами на крижаному континенті перетинатися не доводиться.
До найближчої російської станції - 400 кілометрів.
Але від подій на батьківщині залишатися осторонь неможливо навіть в Антарктиді.
Одна з найкращих новин, навіть ми вже, можна сказати, святкували в той день,  - звільнення Херсона, коли це було.
Так, ще правобережжя в більшості, але все одно.
От Херсонська область, хоча б от та частина людей, бо в нашого кухаря родичі там були,
і ми знали, як от обставини, що там відбувалося.
Ми просто налетіли один на одного: а ти вже чув, ти вже чула?..
Ось такі шеврони серед інших лотів можна було придбати на благодійному аукціоні, який проводили полярники.
Також влаштовували благодійні екскурсії:
люди з усього світу могли спостерігати за тюленями й пінгвінами й водночас допомагати ЗСУ.
Загалом полярники провели три збори.
За перші два вдалося накопичити понад 250 тисяч гривень.
Їх витратили на приціли, тепловізор й антидронову рушницю.
Кошти з третього збору пішли на автомобілі.
Усе - для підрозділів, де служать "бойові пінгвіни" - полярники, які пішли на фронт.
Люди були на сезоні, приїхали на сезон працювати на станції,
і коли почалася війна, вони, скажімо так, змогли сісти, тобто дістатися до України раніше,
ніж повернулася попередня експедиція, ту, яку ми міняли.
На яхтах туристичних, вони дісталися Південної Америки і вже раніше повернулися додому, і пішли вже воювати.
Для Юрія зимівля на "Вернадського" була вже сьомою, для Анжеліки - першою.
Вони ще не вирішили, чи подаватимуться на конкурс, аби поїхати на станцію наступного року.
Головне, кажуть, аби можна було завжди повернутися додому.